PaPakistan.
- - Merci beaucoup Daniel.
- - Bonjour, M. Duclos.
- - Bonjour, Mme Drolet, bonjouà
totous ceux qui nous écoutent.
- - Bon, avec cette annonce
auaujourd'hui, finalement,
vovous envoyez le signal
quque les Canadiens peuvent
sese remettre à voyager.
- - Non, ce n'est pas tout à fat
lele signal qu'on envoie parce e
lala consigne reste la même.
CeCe n'est pas encore le temps
dede voyager. On est encore
enen pandémie. Le virus circule,
leles variants aussi. Une grande
papartie des Canadiens ont déjà
rereçu une première dose.
C'C'est autour de 75 %
dedes 12 ans et plus,
2020 % à peu près ont déjà reçu
unune deuxième dose, comme vous
d'd'ailleurs, mais on n'est pas
rerendu à la fin de la pandémie.
IlIl faut donc être très prudent
etet rester au pays sauf
popour des raisons essentielles.
- - Oui, mais malgré tout,
puisqu'on facilite le retour
popour les gens qui ont eu
leleurs deux doses de vaccin, ps
dede quarantaine pour les adults
vavaccinés deux fois, ça vient
ququand même motiver les gens.
IlIl y a des gens qui ont grand
apappétit de voyage, ça leur a
bebeaucoup manqué.
IlIls vont l'utiliser,
cecette opportunité-là.
- - Oui, on comprend qu'on a tos
enenvie de retrouver comment
c'c'était avant la pandémie,
mamais on n'est pas comment
onon était avant la pandémie.
LaLa pandémie est toujours avec
nonous. Il faut donc être prudet
icici même au pays, mais aussi à
l'l'étranger. Il y a des pays en
dedehors du Canada qui ont des
sisituations sanitaires pires
quque celle du Canada. Donc être
exextrêmement prudent. Évidemme,
ilil y a des mesures qui sont ps
adadaptées pour ceux qui doivent
ouou qui veulent revenir au pay,
etet ça inclut, comme l'avez di,
sisi on est pleinement vacciné,
dede ne pas passer par un hôtelt
dede ne pas faire la quarantaine
sisi, au test de retour,
onon est négatif à la covid.
- - Bon. Là, il y a cet arrimage
didifficile avec le Québec
papar contre sur les conditions
popour éviter la quarantaine.
PaParce qu'au Québec, on conside
ququ'avoir eu la COVID une fois,
plplus une seule dose de vaccin,
çaça, c'est être pleinement
vavacciné, c'est l'équivalent.
CeCe n'est pas ce que reconnaît
avavec les autorités fédérales.
EsEst-ce qu'il va falloir
trtravailler un peu le message,
esest-ce qu'il va falloir faire
dedes ajustements? Parce qu'il a
dedes gens qui ont eu la COVID,
ququi ont eu une seule dose
dede vaccin et qui se disent :
bibien là, c'est un petit peu
ininjuste, je n'ai pas les mêmes
rrègles que les autres,
alalors qu'au Québec, on me dit
quque ça fait la même chose.
- - Bon, il y a trois choses ic.
LaLa première, c'est que
lala science n'est pas encore
tototalement claire là-dessus,
enentre autres sur combien
dede temps on est protégé
cocontre la COVID, du moins
papartiellement en fonction
dudu moment on a eu la COVID.
EsEst-ce que les gens qui ont eu
lala COVID en avril 2020 sont
enencore bien protégés en juin
202021? Donc il y a la science i
n'n'a pas encore parlé clairemet
etet les experts se penche
llà-dessus ces jours-ci.
LaLa deuxième chose, c'est que
lele Québec est la seule provine
àà avoir adopté cette politique
etet comme on est une fédératio,
ilil faut travailler avec
l'l'ensemble des provinces.
LaLa troisième chose, c'est que
leles discussions avec
le gouvernement du Québec vont
trtrès, très bien et on espère
popouvoir montrer des progrès
auau cours des prochains jours.
- - Mais vous convenez qu'il y a
unun arrimage qui doit se faire.
OnOn ne peut pas rester avec une
rrègle comme ça, c'est comme s'l
y y avait de règles à l'intérier
dudu même pays.
- - Tout à fait, il y a des
prprogrès qui doivent être fait.
ExExactement pour la raison que
vovous venez de décrire.
- - Parlons des enfants.
PaParce que là aussi, ça fait
sosourciller un petit peu. On dt
leles adultes vaccinés deux doss
popour pouvoir échapper à la
ququarantaine, évidemment,
sisi leur test est négatif.
MaMais les enfants,
ilils ne peuvent pas se faire
vavacciner, donc pour eux, la
ququarantaine est obligatoire.
EÉcoutez, un enfant mineur,
évévidemment, on ne le laissera
papas tout seul faire ça
ququarantaine. Ça va prendre
ququelqu'un pour le surveiller,
lala plupart du temps, c'est
seses parents. Donc ça revient
unun petit peu au même. Les
paparents se retrouvent avec une
ququarantaine. Il y a même
l'l'association des transporteus
enen avion qui dit : écoutez,
c'c'est de la discrimination ça,
popour les enfants.
- - Mais à nouveau, trois chose:
OnOn est en pandémie, donc il ft
cocontinuer à être très prudent
etet les voyages à l'étranger
sosont fortement déconseillés.
LaLa deuxième chose, c'est que
totout le monde n'est pas vaccié
dedeux fois. On n'a pas atteint
enentre autres le 75 % de
l'l'objectif qu'on s'est donné
popour pouvoir passer à d'autres
ététapes. La troisième chose.
c'c'est que malheureusement,
efeffectivement, les enfants
dede 12 ans qui ne peuvent pas
êêtre vaccinés sont quand même
popotentiellement porteurs
dudu virus et des variants et
ilil faut protéger tout le mond.
EtEt c'est vrai que c'est
trtrès incommodant de surveiller
dedes enfants de moins de 12 ans
popour s'assurer qu'ils font
lala quarantaine, mais c'est
cece qu'il faut faire certainemt
auau cours des prochaines semais
sisi on revient au pays.
- - Maintenant, parlons des
totouristes. Là, c'est une règle
ququi est bonne pour les Canadis
ququi vont revenir de l'étrange,
dodonc le retour va être plus
fafacile, moins coûteux aussi.
PoPour les touristes, est-ce que
çaça veut dire que s'ils sont
vavaccinés deux doses, ils peuvt
vevenir, ici, visiter le Canada?
- - Non, ça ne change rien
popour les touristes. Tout ce qi
chchangent maintenant. ce sont
leles conditions de retour
auau Canada des Canadiens
ouou des résidents permanents.
LaLa frontière reste fermée pour
leles voyages non essentiels
etet donc pour des voyages
totouristiques.
- - Est-ce que ça ne risque pas
dede créer un effet pervers
totout ça pour l'industrie
totouristique canadienne?
C'C'est-à-dire, même si vous ne
rerecommandez pas les voyages,
onon a bien vu dans le temps
dedes fêtes, ce n'était pas plus
mamais on a des Canadiens qui ot
vovoyagé. Alors maintenant,
onon facilite le retour avec cee
rrègle de suspension
dede la quarantaine vous êtes
vavaccinés deux doses. Il y a
dedes gens, évidemment, qui vont
enen profiter. Mais entre-temps,
ilil n'y aura pas de réciprocité
avavec les pays étrangers. Donc
l'l'industrie touristique peut
avavoir l'impression; écoutez,
vovous nous faites perdre des
clclients touristiques,
vovous ne nous donnez pas plus
dedes clients qui nous donnent
dede l'étranger. Donc on est
peperdant deux fois.
- - Mais, je le comprends très
bibien parce que moi, je suis
dédépité de la... de la région e
QuQuébec et l'industrie
totouristique est très forte icà
QuQuébec. C'est un haut lieu du
totourisme canadien et
ininternational. Ceci étant dit,
leles restrictions dont on parl,
leles restrictions touristiques
sosont des restrictions qui sont
sysymétriques. La même chose
s's'applique pour les États-Uni.
LaLa frontière américaine est
totoujours fermée pour les
totouristes américains par la
trtroisième chose, c'est qu'on a
hhâte de passer à une autre
ététape, mais on va y passer pls
rarapidement si on peut passer à
trtravers cette pandémie, donc
cecette crise sanitaire. Ça va e
mimieux en mieux. Le Canada est
paparmi les pays dans le monde,e
prpremier dans les pays du G20 n
tetermes de vaccination est
cecertainement de première dose.
AuAu Québec, on peut s'en réjou,
onon est en avance sur le notre
agagenda. Au cours des deux
prprochaines semaines, 12 millis
dede doses vont être livrés aux
CaCanadiens. Donc ça va très bin
mamais il faut patienter encoren
pepetit peu avant d'aller trop
vivite.
- - Bon, évidemment, tout le moe
sese demande quand est-ce que vs
alallez autoriser justement la
réréouverture des frontières avc
leles États-Unis. Vous avez
enentendu peut-être Monsieur
LeLegault aujourd'hui qui a paré
dede sa vision de ça. Lui, il dt
: : bien d'accord et même contet
ququ'on ouvre bientôt la frontie
avavec les États-Unis, mais il t
: : à des conditions et parmi cs
coconditions, il y a qu'on exige
quque les personnes qui viennent
icici et reçu lors de doses de
vavaccin. Ça, ça va demander
totoutes sortes de négociations
avavec les États-Unis. Je présue
quque vous les avez déjà commens
papar ça doit faire parti de la
liliste des sujets. Est-ce que a
vava être facile de conclure cee
enentente? D'exiger des Américas
vavaccinés quand ils viennent ii
auau Canada?
- - Bien, ces discussions
efeffectivement en cours depuisn
bobon bout de temps pour les
AmAméricains comme nous, on a he
d'd'ouvrir la frontière à un pls
grgrand flux de voyageurs à côté
etet de l'autre de la frontière.
CeCeci étend dit, il y a encore
bebeaucoup d'états. Vous savez,n
a a dépassé les Américains en
mamatière de vaccination. On est
enen haut d'eux alors qu'on est
paparti un peu plus bas au début
paparce qu'on avait pas productn
icici intérieure de vaccin, mais
çaça va très bien au Canada. Mas
çaça ne va pas toujours bien aux
EÉtats-Unis. Donc même si on a
enenvie d'ouvrir la frontière, l
fafaut faire les choses
cocorrectement et ça passe entre
auautres, comme vous l'avez dit,
papar l'établissement de règles
cocommunes, des technologies aui
cocommunes qui vont faciliter
l'l'inscription d'informations r
leles vaccins pour que les gens
pupuissent avoir la facilité mas
auaussi la garantie de traverseà
trtravers les frontières.
- - Mais en fait, ce que
j'j'aimerais savoir de votre pa,
c'c'est : est-ce qu'on s'en va
vevers ça? Est-ce que le Canada
s's'en va vers cette exigence ds
vovoyageurs qui ont de doses de
vavaccin pour les ressortissants
amaméricains qui viendraient ici
enen visite?
- - C'est pas possible parce que
leles Américains ont aussi cette
opopinion qu'il faut du moins pr
unun certain temps s'assurait qe
leles gens qui voyagent et qui
trtraversent les frontières soit
susuffisamment vaccinés pour se
prprotéger eux-mêmes, mais aussi
popour protéger ceux et celles i
vovont aller visiter.
- - Alors reste à voir maintena,
onon le prouve comment? Est-ce e
c'c'est un passeport vaccinal
fifinalement qu'on va avoir ente
leles mains pour franchir la
frfrontière entre les deux pays?
- - Bien, de choses ici, la
prpremière c'est que ce qui s'en
vivient le soir du 5 juillet,
c'c'est un début de passeport
vavaccinal. Ça fonctionne par
l'l'application Arrive Can
ququi fonctionne bien, une
apapplication qui va permettre x
gegens d'inscrire leurs
ininformations de vaccination et
dede pouvoir les valider
lolorsqu'ils vont rentrer au
CaCanada, mais il va y avoir pls
quque ça parce que c'est une
prpremière technologie qui va
fofonctionner rapidement, qui va
bibien fonctionner, mais qui ne
sesera pas aussi robuste que tot
vava vouloir avoir à plus long
teterme. Ce qu'on aura à plus lg
teterme, ça va être parfaitement
inintégré avec la plate-forme
amaméricaine, mais aussi avec
cecelle que d'autres pays
dédéveloppent dans le monde pare
ququ'on a déjà les technologies
lalargement disponibles qui vont
nonous permettre de faire ce
trtravail de manière collaborate
etet efficace avec l'ensemble ds
papays concernés.
- - Est-ce qu'on doit s'attendrà
unune annonce cet été pour
l'l'ouverture des frontières
avavec les États-Unis?
- - Bien, on espère que les chos
vovont continuer d'aller bien et
d'd'aller le plus vite possible.
OnOn est focalisé sur l'opératin
dede vaccination. Pour l'instan,
totous et toutes sont aussi
fofocalisées sur les mesures
sasanitaires qu'il faut continur
d'd'adopter si on veut se
prprotéger, protéger les autrest
sosortir le plus de la pandémie.
- - M. Duclos, merci pour cette
enentrevue.
- - Merci! Une bonne fin de soie
àà vous.
- - Au revoi